[Music]
round five of the norm Congress here in
st. Louis in the Grand Master norm
section Grand Master Vorontsov built an
unstoppable Queen rook battery to bust
through the kingside of international
master Patel all other games were drawn
with four rounds to go so lucky who
still leads the field meanwhile in the
International Master norm section top
seed international masters Sergei met
senko was raining ponds down on
international master Joel Manawa keeping
the Russian favorite a full point above
the nearest competition round six
coverage starts now players all over the
world have struggled to earn the
Grandmaster title which players will
earn a norm which players will go home
with the prize welcome to the 2018 st.
Louis norm Congress
[Music]
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis for the 2018 norm Congress day
four I'm Ben Simon along with
Grandmaster Josh Rydell and we've seen
five rounds played so far today round
six and seven will be played here at the
st. Louis chess club round six is
actually in progress right now and one
of the games has already finished indeed
Justin wing as white defeated tantal
target in the I am norm section so
target moves down to 50% Justin wing
starting to recover from a rough
tournament for him and Justin wing has
earned a norm here before in st. Louis
and I want to talk a little bit about
the norms before we get underway what is
a norm well I'd recommend first of all
going back to day one and watching if
you really want to know in depth because
that's like all we talked about but a
norm is basically a performance standard
if you earn three of them in three
separate tournaments you or earn one per
tournament then you are partially
qualified for the title that you are
pursuing either International master or
the big daddy of them all Grandmaster
Big Daddy I like the Big Daddy
yeah the Grand Daddy I'm gonna call
myself that from now on Thank You Benson
okay where do I start here so besides
the three norms that you need to achieve
you also need a minimum rating a live
rating achieve this rating at any time
and that's as good as as as you need to
be so 2400 is the limit for
International Master 2500 is the minimum
for Grandmaster so once you get that
once you're good you just need to worry
about that absolutely in 1963 you could
hit 2501 and your current rating could
be 2300 but if you get all three
Grandmaster norms guess what you're a GM
you're in just like that so let's take a
look at the rosters here for the players
first of all the grandmasters and the
challengers the up-and-comer is looking
to get a grandmaster norm yep and you
can see this is a
pretty debt dense field and that it's
not the rating gaps are not too huge
Tata's quite a bit lower than the rest
of the field but at the same time she's
certainly holding her own at plus one
stavroula who's the second lowest is
leading the event going to this round
although she's in a bit of trouble I
would say even so ratings do not mean
everything in this and it's really about
whose informant couldn't agree more and
the second section here is for the
International master title norm we have
three international masters here you can
see them near the top and then the
Challenger is pursuing the title and
it's norm indeed and a much bigger gap
you can see this tournament especially
Mott Cinco over a hundred 50 points
above Joba na WA and he is indeed
leading with four to five however he
also could be like the other leader
could be in a bit of trouble so as we
see in these events you never really
know how people whether people are gonna
stay in the lead whether the people in
the back are gonna start moving forward
it's always interesting to watch yeah no
one is too far away from the pack yet
now the tournament format is one of the
easier parts of this event to understand
we have two round-robin events going on
simultaneously and this started on
Thursday it will go through Tuesday the
time control is Damon 90 base time 90
minutes for each player and then each
player gets a 30-second increment that's
30 seconds added on to their clock from
move one so what about the time control
here Josh there's no second time control
it move 40 you don't get like this big
chunk of time at at all and I can tell
you from personal experience that can be
quite harrowing because at first you
think you have a normal time control you
play at your normal place but then when
you get down under five minutes you can
gain some time back with the increment
it helps you out it's not like having no
increment but it's not that much and
when you get low you're low the rest of
the game there's no more going to the
bathroom there's no more long thinks
you're just you don't get a break for
that like button type control to go to
the bathroom take a look at examine the
position see what's happening you have
to stay on your toes the whole game and
I would say that time management is
really important in the side control
because if you get low by move
by move 25 it's a rough day for you
and I can tell you that a lot of the
players are not managing their time
ideally which is just the way it always
works at any level so speaking of time
you know this tournament round has been
going on for three hours by now yeah it
started at 11:00 a.m. I want to take a
look at the full schedule for this event
remember we're on the air every day at
2:00 p.m. and you'll see us live
when these a.m. games are breaking down
but we've had a few days of doubling up
here on Friday Saturday and now Sunday
but the players may get to take a breath
here of relief because tomorrow the
penultimate round is at 11 a.m.
the final round is on Tuesday the 13th
at 11 a.m. and folks I cannot stress
enough tonight we've got round 7 at 5:00
p.m. Central Time we will not be on the
air for that we'll preview a little bit
in this hour and a half or so we
certainly will but first we have quite a
few interesting games to look at so why
don't we take a look at those yes
absolutely let's let's take a look real
quick though at the grandmaster norm
results from round 5 I just to see what
exactly happened this was last night
here at the club all draws except for on
Saab / Patel which you saw in the intro
Patel taking the only loss from last
night indeed pretty solid round and when
everything's a draw it means that the
standings don't move too much but does
not mean that we'll go that way in
future rounds and I would certainly say
that not all these drawers were kind of
dry affairs like a lot of these drawers
had quite a bit of excitement
the Chandra soloqueue game in particular
which looked like it was actually gonna
be a fairly simple draw went a very long
time got to rook and Knight against rook
and only in the end did Chandra hold the
draw so quite an exciting game and on
the other side of the room last night
the 5:00 p.m. around the International
Master results indeed so as we see and
in general usually the IM norm section
will be a bit bloodier that's why we
like to choose red but that's exactly
why it's exactly about it I know that
two draws and yeah Matt saenko took the
lead by beating his cold
into that round Joba na wa Brandon
Jacobsen who was om4 scored a win over
Luis Torres one of the players who was
leading the event so as you can see even
if your own for playing someone three
out of four it's not a foregone
conclusion at all and he won a pretty
nice game tonsil target moving to +1 by
beating Josiah Stearman also so quite an
interesting round and I think we're
gonna have more bloody results in this
round
absolutely so Josh you mentioned you
wanted to get to the games here I know
Justin Wang has won his game already he
has all right let's let's go and take a
look at the games because we are in the
midst of some exciting stuff indeed and
if we talk over at all we're just gonna
miss everything so this was the crucial
moment to me Justin wing is white
against tensile turgut Justin wings
having a bit of a rough event but of
course twelve-year-olds great thing is
usually short memories for these things
they bounce back real fast and he
certainly did that today in this
position I thought that tencel had a
more or less normal opening position but
then he allowed H and H pawn to take on
g6 which was in my view not exactly
ideal and he kind of got a rough
position in my opinion but in this
position he totally got a little too
careless he played the move B 5 and that
allowed a beautiful shot that
twelve-year-olds never gonna miss this
night C takes e5 with the idea that
after Knight takes Knight takes now
tents will play Bishop back d6 but the
idea is that after Queen takes f6 after
Queen takes e5 you play Bishop d4 and
you have this nasty skewer winning the
bishop back and this would be bad news
so he played Bishop e6 but now he's
simply down upon notice how Justin
doesn't even bother defending his Knight
because he still has the same trick
after Queen takes Bishop d4 with the
skewer kids these days they just don't
bother and he won fairly easily from
here Queen d6 they traded bishops he
took on g7 took on h6 better King
up two pawns he tried taking on a2 but
as you can see this King is in trouble
this rooks
and over and it was just a matter of
time before he ran out of checks you
cannot stop Brooke I have three check
tensile two decided to call it a day but
Justin Wayne moves up in tensile turgid
I would say still having an OK event at
50% he's one of the lowest rated in the
event but definitely a disappointing day
for him what I do like though is that he
sort of defies the stereotype which is
that when an older player plays in an
event with a bunch of young kids he's
gonna be the solid guy he's gonna kind
of you know
stay stay tough and all this but almost
all his games have been crazy he's
played some really interesting chess
which I like to see and I definitely you
know prefer that to just plan it say for
every game for sure so we have plenty of
other interesting game so that's over
right yeah so far that I can see that's
the only one that's over there are
plenty of others with lots of action we
might get any finish but we'll keep you
guys posted well before we get to those
Josh Isaac if you could could we take a
look at the pairings for this round the
live pairings because Grandmaster norm
section we didn't really look Lissa's
the hole all the games that are going on
right now for the top section yep and
quite a few interesting ones we're gonna
keep an eye on so lucky though who's the
leader playing Daniel Goodrich she's in
a bit of a tough spot right now but
we'll see if she can dig her way out and
Daniel go to average in last place he
could really use a win in this game
other games we would look at there the
addy Patel game against Marc Parag WA
also very interesting so we'll keep an
eye on all those indeed it is and the
games this round that are going on now -
the Justin Wang victory in the
International Master norm event indeed
grub in ski against Monsanto Mexico in
the clear lead but in some trouble
against Aaron grub in ski we'll see if
he can dig his way out cuz otherwise
he's probably gonna get caught by either
Luis Torres or Joel Bana WA if one of
them wins because they're both a full
point back we'll keep an eye on that
game as well as we mentioned Justin
weighing the only winner thus far but
plenty of other games going on I would
say just a Stearman likely to beat
Brandon Jacobson but apart from that we
have plenty of good games left ok and
let's take a look at some of those
good games Josh what do you have on tap
for us uh so I thought that we would
start with this game between mark Parag
WA and Adi Patel
Adi Patel being white so this game was
just crazy it defied logic for me I
really did not know what was going on
this position looks pretty nice for
white as you can see black's pieces are
completely disorganized white is up pawn
this rook on g5 I don't know what that
guy's about that guy it looks like a
bughouse piece you just put it there for
no reason right it does not look like it
got there by normal means but I assure
you folks this was a chess game but
let's see how this happened because they
had a this position out of the opening
you know it looked like it's a it's a
con Sicilian and Parag WA likes these
kind of double edge games they had this
position a D played Bishop to a3
guarding be too threatening Knight d6
and I thought this night would be pretty
good but Parag was simply ignores it
plays b5 to open up the position for his
pieces rook f5 bringing the rook in
Knight d5 rook h5 Queen h4 and I thought
here that mark was really on his road to
check man I wasn't sure he was gonna get
there right away
but this looks super dangerous all the
black pieces look at this Bishop
pointing down the Knights are ready to
come in this rook might come here this
is a target h2 might become a target all
the blacks pieces look nice whites
pieces I mean this Bishop on a3 can you
really say that's a piece you'd want I
don't think so and to me this looked
really unpleasant but you can see how
quickly everything can change he took on
d5 eliminating that piece it's Queen
back to c1 mark played rook to g5 which
seems logical trying to target g2 but
after Bishop f3 you close down this a8
Bishop and that's an important thing
because if that Bishop were to get in
the game it would be
really dangerous but here somehow he
just wasn't able to bring anything into
the party he played d5 which is a move I
really would rather not play because now
your bishop really gets blocked but he
wants to play 95 the problem is that
after g3 he doesn't really have much to
do
note how you're not attacking this Queen
just yet because the pin however you're
just probably gonna just give a nice
safe square for your Bishop and it's
hard to meet someone when they have a
bishop on g2 it's just a really nice
defensive piece mark plays 95 Bishop d2
Queen h5 now note how the Queen's attack
because the bishop blocks this rook here
and now he plays Bishop e7 saying hello
rook probably didn't know that rook
could be attacked and now he has to make
a decision do I say that rook or do I
not say that rook marks of an aggressive
player I'll give you a choice did he
save that Rutger what do you think then
he played d4 he's like half my rook
please I beg of you
it works not doing a lot right now
seemingly right that's true it's like
you know losing a rook is not bad if the
rook is useless I like this rule don't
bother about defending your pieces guys
just defend the pieces that are doing
something I'm joking of course but d4
has a nasty little trick if you play
Queen takes g5 I play Knight f3 check
your Queens attacked if King H won of
course
Queen takes h2 maid I'm not gonna bother
taking your queen so bishop would have
to take Queen takes f3 this Bishop on a8
which I said was dead a move ago not so
dead now Queen g2 and Queen h1 are both
made threats I would say this position
is resigning because there's no way to
block this Bishop or sacrifice for it or
anything like that so this position
looks dead I'm sure he won't be doing
that
and after d4 he's having a thing so we
have to decide like what's he gonna do
how is he gonna deal with this threat
and it could be Bishop g5 Bishop e7 was
a little careless maybe he missed this
opportunity I'm not exactly sure but
let's see because it's not you're not
obligated to take the rook by any means
one move that might have to be looked at
is the simple capture Knight takes d4 so
the idea of this is that now Knight f3
is covered
you can't eliminate the bishop on g2 you
can play a move like Bishop takes g2 and
I might even think about Queen takes g5
but also even after King takes bishop
I'm not quite seeing what Mark's plan
would be it seems like f3 with f3
covered it's just limited what you can
do you could try Knight g4 threatening
the h2 I might even be able to grab this
rook because I do have an escape square
on f3 but even if I have to play h3 it
just looks like your pieces are in a
tangle they're not really doing too much
so and indeed he did play Knight takes
d4 as we can see and I'm really curious
what marks gonna come up with he's a
resourceful guy but it just looks like a
difficult position to me he just doesn't
quite have enough for all this and as
often happens when you put your pieces
end up on awkward squares Queen on h5
rook on g5 it's hard to orchestrate them
in an attack so I'll keep an eye on this
we'll see what happens but my guess
would be that mark is actually gonna
lose and Adi Patel is gonna move up and
recover nicely from his loss last night
there are some definitely some other
games we can look at I'm very interested
to see what happened in this game
between camera cool of and verone's off
two other guys who definitely I want to
keep an eye on I believe both of them go
to Texas Tech in Lubbock if I'm not
mistaken and let's see so there are
teammates is that correct I think
brought so for sure is as we know hammer
cool off maybe not yet yeah I didn't
think ok yep that was my mistake
but yeah but also of Texas Tech student
in Lubbock and let's see what happened
because this game there was a very
confusing moment to me it was this
moment in the opening looks like a
relatively normal position it's kind of
a Kings Indian structure blacks in to
play Knight g7 eventually try to play it
for f5 white usually plays on the Queen
side with moves like a 4b for bringing
the night in rook b1 this is at least
how I know how to play this position but
karma cool off had other ideas
and I saw this move I had to adjust my
glasses for a moment cuz I wasn't quite
sure this was actually the move played
and the idea is very simple he wants to
control f5 but honestly to me this looks
a little dangerous and after Knight f6 h
3 h 5 it seems like his King side just
got opened up and I was not a fan so
Knight h2 King g7 bringing a rook to the
H file and quite honestly I feel like
this whole thing backfired he played c4
just to make sure the pawn center is
secure but really this looked quite
unpleasant he brings the knight in
notice how blacks just maneuvering all
his pieces in threatening Bishop to g5
and now came a very interesting moment
obviously black could play a move like
Queen h8 but okay I'm not so sure he has
anything concrete plan obviously rook
takes Knight is a powerful move but even
after something like rook h3 maybe it's
not so simple to break through no doubt
f3 is covered by the Queen this is
rather important ripped a stage to
ripped a stage to doesn't do much maybe
he could just keep building Queen h7
rook h8 it looks like a pretty tough
situation to be honest but black chose
to actually just take this Knight
immediately quite an interesting
sacrifice the idea is that Queen h8
check King g1 Queen h4 and now this
night does not have a happy square and
what happens tonight's when they don't
have a happy square they happen to find
an unhappy select okay that square would
be Knight h1 and quite a move but it
does hold on temporarily he takes on e1
and this is the trick because if you
play rook h8 Bishop g2 then I donate
what each one may look silly but it
actually guards a couple crucial squares
and maybe not so simple but Pablo fons
finds a nice tactic Queen take c1 a nice
little shot the idea being after Queen
take c1 Knight takes F 3 check grab the
Queen and black simply finds himself up
upon and I think better positionally so
I would say this game black is headed
towards Victor he checks and attacks and
double does the double attack bishop c8
hitting that G pawn
Bishop d7 next he's gonna bring his rook
in sure enough rook h8 and the current
in the current position he played b4
understandable White's just trying to
make the game complicated so at least
black doesn't just win immediately but
quite honestly this looks just painful
at the moment this Bishop doesn't have
any great discoveries if it moves keep
in mind you hit this Bishop on h3 but
honestly you don't necessarily need
anything great in a position like this
it wouldn't surprise me if he even just
takes this B pawn and after Bishop takes
b6 simply moves the bishop and asking
what are you gonna do with this guy
maybe Knight f2 kind of holds on you're
tempted to sack o on h3 but maybe dunno
not working so I don't know maybe this
is actually not the cleanest way I'm
sure he'll find something nice though I
mean it's just pretty ugly position it's
even a move like Bishop g5 is probably
not ridiculous
the idea being after taking the bishop
you take here and these pawns are just
too weak there's just no way to guard
everything and really it's just a matter
of technique at this point so he does
actually take on b4 so I'll be
interested to see what happens after
Bishop takes pawn I'm sure there has to
be something it's just this is just too
flimsy Knight on h1 usually when pieces
are this ugly there's something good
tactically tactics will tend to work in
your favor
maybe this idea here is simply Bishop e1
I don't know the idea being that now you
cover the square for the knight so
there's no Knight to f2 and again if
Ruka takes Bishop rook takes h3 this G
pawn is just a goner
I don't know again if this is the
cleanest way but it certainly looks very
strong and again it could have something
much simpler here you know it's it just
looks like a pretty bad position so
we'll keep an eye on this but I have a
feeling that Virant Civ is going to reel
in the point here it certainly looks
like a josh and in the International
Master norm section Joel ba da WA has
clinched a victory against Louise Torres
yeah it looked like a blunder from
Torres so they reached this position and
again it looks like White's doing okay
he's doubles up black
the two bishops but quite honestly the
bishops don't make a very powerful
impression this pawn on e4 looks like a
nice pawn but it blocks off all blacks
pieces and Torres simply gangs up on
this D pawn takes it however but now I
had a very sneaky idea here rather than
take with the bishop which of course
looks very logical rook takes and I
don't know I mean at the moment this
rook is pinned but at the same time it
should be fairly easy to get out of the
pin eventually instead he actually opts
to take with the rook and now after rook
takes he simply plays the waiting move
f6 looks like a ridiculous move but it
does two things first of all it kills
this bishop not like that's necessarily
crucial but it always is nice and the
idea is that now if white plays f4 you
do not have to take this this rook on d5
like this after which black white
couldn't even just play Queen takes and
is probably doing more than okay here
the bishop comes to d4 I like White's
position actually but instead he plays
Queen f7 and there's just not a lot
going on so and in fact this is what
happened Queen f7 and now the problem is
this rook just cannot move and after
rook 1 d2 black plays rook d8 and he
actually just resigns note by the way
how if he had if he had taken with the
bishop he might be able to take this
rook followed by taking this rook there
would be a rook on e8 here rather than a
bishop on b7 so it's one of those rare
cases you'd actually rather have the
bishop because now after rook takes rook
Queen takes Queen you're simply down two
rooks for a queen and a bishop and it's
simply too much the e pawn is weak the
rooks are not doing anything super
special the Queen it's just a matter of
the time till the Queen cleans
everything up so quite a quite a
tactical blunder by Louise Torres and
what I thought was just a fairly normal
game I'm not sure if he was better or
not but it looked like just very normal
but as you can see you got to pay
attention from the very start because
one questionable move and things can go
very poorly for you very fast
another result in the Grandmaster norm
section Akshat Chandra with the black
pieces has defeated Denish barouche
alright let's take a look at this one
this game I didn't have as close an eye
on however let's see what happened to
the final position he he resigned before
white black could play the tactic it
looks like blacks almost made it here
for example if the knight moves
somewhere random let's even say if 97
you get mated very embarassing and if 95
check he had the really nice idea of
Knight takes and it looks like oh you're
real Kang's but now you give a check
take it back c6 is hanging so it's like
everything's good right
however he resigned and in fact he did
wait for the move he resigned because
black has rook takes Knights and now the
tactic works against you right if rook
takes rook fork the king and queen or
king and rook whichever one you prefer
and there's no check on h8 notice
because the night covers very important
so yeah
this position of course it was hopeless
anyway I'm sure that Danish saw the move
but after f5 there's not much you can do
here you're just down too much material
with your pieces pinned that's usually a
sign of bad things to come so quite a
quite a tough loss for Danish buttocks
Chandra who was struggling for the
beginning part of the tournament
starting to move him we're seeing that
in other sections as well I think that
the guys at the bottom are not planning
on staying at the bottom and they're
getting some nice wins so for sure yeah
absolutely and if you want to watch
these games as they're happening if
you're not there already check out us
chest champs dot-com there's a really
cool feature where this video is
actually embedded in the upper right
corner of their chests 24 module so it's
us chest champs calm it's the best way
to watch chess check it out if you're
not there already indeed so I figured I
would move unless there's another result
which I'm not catching we're trying to
keep an eye on all the results but
sometimes there's quite there's 10 games
going so sometimes we might forget about
one for the moment but I assure you it's
not going to be a permanent thing three
games over right now in both sections
right now we've covered those yeah so
I'm gonna move to the game between sir
game at Cinco and Aaron gourbin ski garb
in ski as white is actually up a queen
for a rook and two pawns so what might
sank was hoping for is that he can hold
a fortress here basically what that
means is keep it so that obviously he's
not trying to win anything but if he can
keep white at bay keep it so the Queen
and King cannot penetrate the black
position sometimes you can actually draw
with this much material I kind of have
my doubts I have a feeling that if White
knows what they're doing here they'll be
able to break this down but you never
know these positions are very tricky and
sometimes when you least expect it they
there are ways to win but I suspect this
is a win y can probably play something
like he played kini to in the game I
thought King g2 maybe but maybe doesn't
matter that much and the idea is that
this G pawn is actually quite weak so if
you're not careful I'm just gonna play
Queen d2 Queen g5 something like this
and if you try to push your B pawn I
simply check go behind and then snack it
snack on it and I think that that's
gonna be probably enough it's just too
much material for there really to be a
fortress here that's the general rule if
there's not that much left on the board
fortresses are possible as it is I'd say
it's very unlikely but again you never
know sometimes there are interesting
possibilities but let's see how this
happened because you're asking how did
the top seed rated 25 60 higher than
anyone in the GM norm section get such a
lost position right let us see so this
position actually was it started off way
before this actually in this position I
thought that Black was just doing okay
or I thought black would trade off
pieces on the C file likely a draw but
as you can see White's pieces are kind
of swarming around the black King here
and if you give them too many moves
guess what you might end up checkmate it
so black played Queen d89 g4 and here
black tried the shot Knight takes h4 my
guess is this is not a winning attempt
simply because it looks super dangerous
I thought that black might try rook
takes c1 but it could be that already
there are moves like shots like Knight
tastes h6 check in the air the idea
being that after pawn takes Queen takes
you're threatening Queen g7 mate and if
you block that with Queen f8 you allow
Knight to f6 with mates and that's not
fun
well it is for whites in any case he
played Knight takes 84 check which looks
like such a clever shot the problem is
that because you sack to piece White
says alright now it's my turn
Knight f6 check pawn takes knight takes
f6 check and again I mean there are lots
of possibilities here I thought Knight
takes h6 check was possible with idea
that a pawn takes Queen takes you're
threatening lots of mates again however
maybe it's just his king just doesn't
have any shelter here so black can keep
giving checks and that's usually a
problem that blacks just tried for a
perpetual here so white chose this one
rook takes c7 and rook III this was
actually a really interesting moment I
thought at first that white would play
rook h1 and that the game was
essentially over the reason being that
after Queen g5 check I thought you trade
and have mate but because you've moved
this pawn after rook check notice how if
King e7 rook e8 is checkmate very common
check mating pattern but after King g7
the King has a little bit of breathing
room and that's all you need you can
still give a perpetual something like
this going here would not be recommended
due to MIT but you go back and there's
just somehow no mate and notice after
rook H a king here you can grab this
rook but it's not quite winning because
you can take this rook on h8 so there's
just no way to do it honestly it looks
like a really good position for white
even if you play a move like rook b8
rook d8 even though blocks up a pawn it
looks much more pleasant for the white
pieces that being said doesn't mean that
it's not clear or that easy even after
rook b8 threatening this and this for
example you can play rugby 7 however
Aaron found something which was quite
interesting he played rookie 3 which has
a beautiful trick to it if Queen g5
check which looks like a strong move
because now you pin the rook to the
Queen White says alright fine enjoy and
the problem now is that after Queen
takes Queen rook GA check
and that is me and notice how even if
the king could move to g7 rook g8 his
mate because there's a pawn on h6 so it
kind of hurt you so his idea was simply
to play rook g3 and code for this kind
of mate black played King e7 and h5 the
idea being black wasn't just white
wasn't just threatening rook GA let's
say you play a move like Bishop b7 roof
g4 oops that Queen is trapped you would
have to sacrifice your bishop like this
which is actually an interesting try
because now if King takes bishop you can
play even Oh No rook c1 check doesn't
work cuz I can take you and if you try
to skewer me I can block but you can
play Queen h1 Queen h3 but honestly
you're down a piece I don't think it's
gonna work out too well for you so in
the game he played h5 to cover this rook
g4 move and again I thought that white
should have something really punishing
here just look like one of those
positions you have to be careful if you
try to trap the Queen with rook h3
bishop f1 check is a nasty shot and you
actually lose so don't avoid that don't
play into that boys and girls however
there's nothing there was nothing that
really jumped out at me I really wanted
to get the Queen to this diagonal so I
was trying to find ways to do it I was
looking at b4 I was looking at other
things but after before okay if black
takes you look like a genius go me
however black maybe could try and move
like rook c4 with the idea of taking on
d4 and again my feeling was that this
should probably work but I just couldn't
make do it and again least for these
players it's much harder than for me I'm
just sitting here making moves if I make
a mistake it's not a big deal I just
embarrassed myself happens all the time
but for these players it's really
difficult because they make one little
slip and a lot of their work goes down
the drain in any case even after Queen
takes d4 here maybe rook takes d4 maybe
it's not super simple but I thought this
before idea was kind of what I was
focused on he played Queen h6 which
actually is a beautiful trick for
example if you play Queen takes d4
thinking nothing's happening I
understand rook e8 looks dangerous and
may actually rook e8 maybe just the job
here I should have found it more
but the cool thing is rook g8 is not as
forcing you allow quit take c5 view of
the beautiful shot Queen of fate check
must take the Queen and now you mate so
queen h6 was a very sneaky move
threatening Queen f8 black could defend
in a couple ways Bishop b5 covering this
square would do it so you can't mate
there he chose rook c8 but now Aran
review reveals the second idea rook g4
and the whole idea is that this pawn is
now pinned so black has to take with the
Queen in order not to lose even more
material takes and I thought that here I
really thought that Aaron would have
cleaned up this position not easily but
I thought this should be a win he
surprised me here by playing Queen d2 I
thought for sure he would just take this
pawn and maybe I'm missing something but
I thought that this was relatively clean
for example if you try rook to c2 white
threatening this pawn kind of getting
counter plays seemingly you can play
Queen f3 the King moves back because
otherwise if you lose this you're dead
and now Queen b3 hitting the baroque and
hitting this pawn so I thought this was
pretty good maybe he was worried about
something like Bishop coming here and
then trying to sneak back here and maybe
trying to hold honestly I have a hard
time believing it's holdable there's
this weakness to work on the King can
run into f6 at some point I'd say it's a
pretty difficult position for black to
really think about holding but they're
always chances and now let's fast
forward to the game at some point he did
get this position which to my eyes looks
pretty good he doesn't really want the
g4 pawn for some reason but he gets this
he goes after these pawns and yeah I
mean at this point it looks like he
should be winning fairly comfortably
she plays b4 ace a5 so this is how he
wins this Bishop honestly I feel like he
could take even take the time to take
this pawn and this might even be simpler
and then just go back and push and it
looks pretty hopeless but he chose a a5
a six got a sack the bishop and now you
come to this position where he's trying
to get the fortress and again it's
always a little nerve-wracking because
during a game you never really know if
it's a fortress and if you stumble into
a fortress accidentally it can be the
worst feeling in the world because you
did all this work you got the material
you got a winning position against such
a strong player but Josh what for those
who may not know what exactly is a
fortress and so a fortress is basically
a position that is impenetrable you have
you might be down material or look for a
queen you know whatever the material
might be but if you have it so that
every weakness is covered in your
opponent cannot make any progress their
King can't move forward they can't start
attacking too much with their queen
basically it means you have everything
covered so that even though you can't do
anything they cannot make progress is
what a fortress is they happen in end
games one of the simplest examples it
would be if you have a king and your
opponent has a bishop and a rook pawn
and their Bishop is not the same colors
your queening square if you get your
king to that queening square it's a draw
and the reason why is it's a fortress
there's just no way for white to try to
win without still meeting you it's one
of the really embarrassing ones you
can't force the King out of the corner
no way to force the King out of the
corner and if you try you just end up
still mating the King so while your
opponent can donate the game to you with
best play it is most certainly a draw so
let's go to the starting position and
let's see if we can figure out whether
this is a fortress so again his idea
would be he got this and this and it
looks like White's king can't get in
everything's covered right the problem
with such fortresses usually is that
there are a little too delicate note how
this g4 pawn is not defended I'm sure
Aaron were wishing he took that pawn
earlier in the game at one of his
chances but at the same time I'm not so
sure exactly how it works but okay let's
see what could happen here I think that
white should try to activate the Queen
if you have a passive Queen there's no
way you're gonna try to really be able
to win this game so I thought he might
try something like queen a3 check King
up and then try to bring the Queen in
somehow so for example a move like Queen
e7 would be fairly logical trying to
shoot for here again it's important that
after b2 you can always slide back and
collect this pawn you have to be careful
of tactics of course
for example after g3 you have to make
sure that nothing horrible happens to
you notice if the rook were here you
could actually have a problem because
rook check and ruining stuff but here
you can indeed take this pawn and after
rook check King f2 and this is a
position where your black can try to set
up a fortress by doing something like
this I realize guys this is way far from
the game but just to show you kind of
how it works in this position if black
can say I'm gonna just sit and you can't
break through this is a fortress the
problem is you can run your opponent out
of moves for example you play Queen b8
or is it well black has to make a move
first say King g6 Queen B 8 so now black
doesn't want to let you in you say okay
I'll pass and the problem you have here
is that you always need to make a move
so in order to establish a fortress you
don't just need a position where you
have where you're where you have a
position where your opponent can't break
through you actually need to you need
two positions because if you only have
one position it means that your opponent
can run you out of moves and chess you
always have to make a move if that
weren't the case black could just sit
here and kind of relax chill out with a
beer say you're never getting in but not
how chess works it doesn't look that
simple but the idea is that if the King
moves somewhere you can place a queen h8
and you just run your opponent on it
moves here there are checks there are
things like this so I don't think it's
actually that simple to just break down
all these fortresses but quite honestly
I don't think that it's gonna work for
example if you keep checking most likely
the king should actually come around
this way note how the nice thing is when
your opponent is playing for a fortress
you have all the time in the world and
the problem is when the King gets to e7
let me just show you how to break a
fortress essentially so let's say black
just kind of sits here there's not much
black can really do to be honest but
okay let's see if you can break a
fortress is it really a fortress at all
oh wow we're getting close guys I've
watch out I watched it then I would say
it's a failed four okay I guess very
good point yeah but okay if your King
gets cut off it's gonna be very easy you
simply run your king
keep in mind all the time in the world
and then you take this pawn that
fortress is
caput so you might even be able to run
the King out of moves but of course it's
unnecessary the point being that I doubt
that this is a fortress
so King goes to g7 and here White has to
decide how to force this though because
black does not have to play b2 after a
move like Queen e7 for example he didn't
play this he played king d2 so his idea
actually is to cover the b-pawn with the
King and slide the Queen over to take
care of other business but I'm not so
sure black plays rook f3 here and again
he needs a move probably the King would
have to move back I would imagine maybe
these ideas just to play Queen e7 and
part with this pawn but somehow this
doesn't look like the most solid way to
do things you play King g6 note how you
cover this square
there's Queen h4 but now you allow rook
f4
this does not look like a good way to do
things no no this pawn is still there
you know I mean it's probably not gonna
create a queen but in any case after
king d2 he's still thinking but I would
imagine that rook f3 is coming and again
I'm just not quite sure what his plan is
and how he's gonna break this down at
the moment I would say that he needs to
get the Queen in run the King out of
moves it looks like it shouldn't quite
hold but at the same time you still need
to prove it and he has to do that so
it's kind of a it's one of those tricky
situations where you have to be a little
bit careful not saying this is a
fortress but it's a position where you
know things can go wrong you cannot win
this position so sometimes then earlier
in the game when you have a chance to
take those little pawns if you if you're
not in a rush and you take those pawns
and then try to win sometimes it's just
easier not that this isn't a win but
it's a little bit easier sure enough you
did play rook up three and again this is
one of the marks of a strong player that
oh gosh I'm sorry the repla no Braddy
patel has clinched a victory just wanted
to let everybody know in the GM the one
field hopefully we'll be able to talk to
addy a little bit later on that would be
good and an important win for him but
yeah as I was just saying about the
fortress sometimes you take those little
pawns take your time it can be a little
bit easier but we're seeing Matt Sango
one of the reasons why he is one of the
strongest players players like this our
hard to close out because they never
quite give up they are always coming up
with resources so the idea of sacking
the bishop was kind of forced but at the
same time he found a way to at least
make like difficult so I'm still looking
for a groom in situ come away with the
wind but let's see how mark lost I did
think his position was quite bad but
let's see so a lot happened since we
were last there this is what happens in
this time control guys you think you
have plenty of time to go over stuff but
then thing life comes at you fast been
so Knight takes d4 takes g2 rook f5 and
Adi says you know what I'm just gonna
take that it's possible to leave the
rook there and quite honestly that also
looks winning but he decides just to
take and it seems like nothing's gonna
happen he could have thrown in a check
on f3 here may be taken on f5 after that
probably doesn't make a huge difference
the knight and queen look nice together
but they're not necessarily doing too
much white plays Queen f4 putting an end
to those thoughts grabs b2 sometimes
even sacrificing an important pawn like
a b2 pawn is worth it if you can just
trade off those Queens simplify the game
so he plays a3 Bishop c5 rook e1 and
there's just not much you can do here he
Forks but the bishop simply drops back
very safe
rook d3 know what how he's taking his
time he's not in a rush he's making sure
everything's covered rook comes over so
the idea is now if you try to grab this
pawn I'm guessing that the rook just
comes into the seventh and indeed he
plays rook d8 so this Bishop on a fake
now is in pretty dire straits and Mark
just couldn't find a way to save it he
played king f7 rook b7 check and he gave
up the ghost because it should be seven
here you play this the pin is too strong
so nice win for a D and Mark goes down
to three out of five so he's having a
bit of a rough event now I wouldn't say
he's doing horribly but considering he
was in the clear lead and looking pretty
good things have gone pretty rough for
him since that being said of course
still a few rounds to go I would not
write him off but definitely a tough
blow and a nice win for Adi Patel who's
the plus column I believe yes and
furthermore in the International master
norms section 14-year old Josiah
Stearman has increased the bad
tournament that brand of Jacobson is
having a brandon has one win so far but
that game has since ended as well yep
and this game actually there was a
really crucial moment because I think
that Brandon had maybe a winning
position it was earlier in the game
queen g4 happened queen takes e5 and at
this point I thought that Josiah had
played a little recklessly and I didn't
see what he would do after a move like
Bishop c4 pinning the knight to the rook
and the idea is that if you defend the
knight and I play rookie eights I'm just
gonna take your queen or if you move I'm
gonna take your knight that's a whole
piece so after Bishop c4 he'd most
likely move his Knights somewhere I
don't know where exactly let's say g3
but that's an exchange and quite
honestly if the rook gets to the 7th and
you're up the exchange you're probably
winning here so I would suspect that
Brandon was actually winning
he played f6 which looked maybe ok
you're gonna play Bishop Seabourn next
but Josiah found the nice Intermezzo in
between move h3 hitting that Queen and
after takes it still maybe not bad for
black however he ended up losing this
epon and then white has this very nice
pawn chain on the Kings side his rooks
gonna come in here he still looks like
an unclear position but from this point
on it seems like Brandon just got
outplayed and sometimes this happens
when you're having a rough event things
can still go your way but it seems like
everything just goes against you you
have a good position you somehow lose it
and I know this feeling really well but
some events just it seems like nothing
goes your way he had a nice win last
round but yeah h5 I think is a really
bad idea in this position maybe he's not
doing so badly
it still looks rough he's gonna take
this beep on and come in notice how the
king is black's main problem here more
than the pawns but he maybe would have
holding chances if he had kind of bunker
down it already looks bad but h5 is just
desperation and after
five his life is just really terrible
these pawns are way too strong and he
sacrifices a piece to get out but once
you sack a piece you're pretty much dead
and the game lasted a while oh this is
kind of nice
what happened well his knight got his
knight got trapped somehow I don't know
why he put his 9 on h4 but he gets out
of it with a chain and wins the rook
back maybe unnecessarily but a nice
little tactical flourish a lot of the
time technique actually does include
lots of tactics so just because you're
up a piece doesn't mean you stop looking
and here he tries to play for mate but
he might get made it himself and
eventually there are lots of maneuvering
lots of dancing lots of shaking but
eventually he did get things done
definitely some time pressure here
because these are not the most accurate
of moves but finally pins the King to
the back rank usually a good start
brings his King in and yeah this is just
over surprise he has to do this but it's
the way it goes once he wins the pawn he
just organizes his pieces and this was
pretty much then they played it out I'm
guessing cuz again there wasn't much
time definitely not the smoothest of
technique but at the same time and then
a nice little flourish again not
necessary by any means you could just
defend this Knight but King here with
the threat of mates so he gotta win any
other results that you want to bring up
I do see that
Josh colos won as well as black yeah we
haven't taken a look at that game yet
absolutely today I believe no we haven't
and this was it looked like Josh just
kind of had the upper hand most of the
way he got to summit he got to this
endgame and he's just up upon opposite
Bishop endgame White has some activity
but quite honestly it's a pretty nice
pawn
she asked this knight on e6 she does
which is not a bad piece but it also
doesn't attack too much and eventually
he trades it off and again opposite
pitcher Bennigan's always some chances
but I would say it's kind of rough
especially with this weak e3 pawn
definitely looks like it some drawing
chances here but eventually she was
outplayed and he was able to break
through she actually took this pawn on
e6 but now
the c3 pawn is hanging and this is a
problem because if you take I play rook
takes those rooks are rather menacing
and not a lot you can do for example if
rook f1 I check and pin your rook and if
you go King d1 I check and take this
rope just off your hands entirely so the
problem is she went back the pawn but
there were lots of dynamics but even
here I mean she won her back her pawn
but this is eventually gonna come this
pawn is a bit weak Bishop a4 was maybe
kind of rough but at the same time still
a tough position so even though she went
back her pawn her misery did not quite
end and eventually Josh was able to reel
in the point as we're seeing lots of
moves keep in mind these guys didn't
probably have almost no time so the
likelihood that these are all accurate
moves is unlikely but this pawn is
likely to win a bishop this pawn note
how the bishop is not the same color or
rather is the same color as this square
very important may not matter too much
in the end but should be good enough
using tactics to in his favor if rook
takes pawn there's rook check take the
bishop and if you try to attack the rook
I can simply move the back and should be
easily winning always tactics and
technique but here he simply uses the
King to win the bishop and this is a
very simple position you simply
outmaneuver this King eventually you
come back for example if this you'll go
here there's no way to trade off these
pawns and the King will simply
outmaneuver you using the bishop as it
helpful King comes in this would be the
end
so after King g2g you decided to call it
a day so tough loss for her she's having
a rough event I think only two draws so
far but she is out rated by almost
everyone and Josh colas I think at
plus-2 now I want to say so he is moving
up let us see indeed Josh colas at +2
Josh colas a 19 year old now resides in
st. Louis
guys bailout and stuff so yeah so
definitely the locals will be cheering
for him I do see that we have another
result a couple actually pavlova ronzo
did be hammer cool off so as predicted
looks like kind of a painful position
last we saw it was this position and it
looked like black was winning he chose
to do it this way attacking the C pawn
and there's just no good way to guard
this guy if you play rook c1 you give up
the a pawn this is what happens when all
your pawns are weak so he gave up the
Jeep on but not not a very difficult
technical task he decided to trade
everything which is not the most
aesthetic way to do it but at the same
time this is the way - this is the way
professionals have to do things and this
is a very simple win just way too much
and the b1 Bishop is gonna fall now
because you have to move the rook away
so that was that and there was another
game there was a draw between our
leaders tough ruler so lucky to against
Daniel go Trebek I thought guru David
she was gonna win this game so I'm very
curious how she managed to save it got
to a queen end game my goodness Wow
again this happens when the players just
don't have that much time but I thought
that Gurevich was well on his way to
victory last I saw was around here and
Gurdev inches up a pawn it's the Z pawn
which doesn't look super strong however
there's this nice pin and there's this
weak pawn on h3 so he simply goes after
it I thought you would just give up this
pawn maybe take here play here and maybe
try to do something with the King like I
guess King f2 runs into a rock h2
probably this is a rough a rough go of
it but I don't know maybe she could try
rook a two days six it looks bad
she tried rook h2 which is not the
prettiest move on the planet but at the
same time holds the Aged pump but she
did find a nice resource here with E 5
and this makes life a little bit more
complicated maybe Daniel should have
taken an extra move to play King d6 just
to prevent the c5 resource I'm not sure
but he did allow it and after this
somehow she got enough counter play she
he plays back to d6 the ideas of King
here
run into this so he plays King d6 takes
King d5 the idea now of course and just
cuz it's an end game as I mentioned
doesn't mean there aren't some tactics
now the ideas of f4 rook takes h3 check
[Music]
so and this actually happens King c4
takes on e5 but this is a lot of
liquidation and somehow Daniel was just
not able to win this game she brings the
King back to be to rook g3 and now they
actually trade to a king in pawn a queen
endgame my guess would be that after
rook check or rook h3 of trying to
protect here you play rook check rook
here attacking this guy rook here and
it's just it's hard to win a rook
endgame let me tell you this is pretty
liquidated so my guess would be allowing
that a five-shot was not so good but
very resourceful by her in a position
where it looked like things were bad
they trade to a queen endgame the
general rule for queen end games is that
if the king is in front like it is here
it's usually very difficult to win
because the King just can't find shelter
and it's hard to trade Queens when their
opponents King is in front in front of
the in front of in front of this pawn
yes okay if your King can't be in front
here's the rule you want to actually be
as far away as possible because then
there are fewer checks believe it or not
ah that get in your way the worst place
to be is somewhere like here or here
because then there are all sorts of
blocking checks which trade queens but
the best place to be is in front and
that's where she found herself so she
started checking notice how there are
also stalemate tricks you know for
example if the Queen were to be given
away here would be stalemate so also
something to look for but she simply
gives too many checks and there's just
no way to get out of them notice how for
example even a queen trade here with the
King back on b1 would be a draw you do
not come up allowing this which would
lose simply go to c1 and this King is no
good moves if it comes up here you go
here king before king d2 simply going
for the opposition
so he played King XIII she gave checks
they finally traded but she was careful
she played here King c4 and now King
here getting the opposition and they
played it out cuz why not always fun to
play it out I'm sure they did it quickly
I like when people play it out real fat
like what if it's really long then it
gets ridiculous but just to show the
fans look we didn't stop trying it
really is a draw I swear
so stavroula will at least maintain a
time for the lead here by this draw
however she might be joined by Tata
Abraham yang I'd like to look at that
game after our break here all right
we're gonna take a moment off the air
and then we'll be right back with you
for the rest of today's round six for
the st. Louis norm Congress you're
watching it on us chest champs calm
we'll see you in just a moment question
on Twitter from dem s I should not have
pronounced that that was a bit of a
champion
for those of you who are new to chess it
might look like ba 3 is an illegal move
here because white advances pawn to
square is not one but it still is
something we call Oprah song and you can
do that by you have to do it instantly
you can't wait for a move like let's say
clay king in seven Kingi - and now try
because y'all played four against
Lawrence and now he's going to play
something against me which we discussed
at length during the course of my stay
yeah he told me this is that d5 this was
what I was kind of hoping for because
now I think we might as well know who
Lawrence this is not how chess works
certainly would be much much more fun if
chess actually work like this I don't
think it does well maybe it does well
that's me regretting what I just said
how did I get from there to here is a
little bit beyond me and what's worse I
will never hear the end of my quality of
life has just gone downhill tremendously
because I'm actually sharing the office
with the guy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you could fly to Venice
or Paris or even Copenhagen
you could fly all over the world but why
when you could just come to st. Louis
your trip begins at explore st. Louis
calm a moment comes in chess when you
need to test yourself at a different
level chess 24 premium offers the tools
that you need to reach your maximum
potential from hundreds of interactive
video lessons to becoming part of the
chess 24 community you can analyze with
friends or coach your students live you
get twenty four by seven coverage of
chess news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just twenty four premium membership
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
[Music]
[Music]
you could fly to Venice
[Music]
or Paris or even Copenhagen
you could fly all over the world but why
when you could just come to st. Louis
your trip begins at explore st. Louis
calm a moment comes in chess when you
need to test yourself at a different
level chess 24 premium offers the tools
that you need to reach your maximum
potential from hundreds of interactive
video lessons to becoming part of the
chess 24 community you can analyze with
friends or coach your students live you
get twenty four by seven coverage of
chess news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just twenty four premium membership
[Music]
[Music]
you could fly to Venice
or Paris or even Copenhagen
you could fly all over the world but why
when you could just come to st. Louis
your trip begins at explore st. Louis
calm question on Twitter from dem s I
should not have pronounced that that was
a bit of a champion for those of you who
are new to chess it might look like ba 3
is an illegal move here because white
bounces pong two squares not one but it
still is something we call hustle and
you can do that but you have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a move like
let's say clay King in seven games you -
and I'll try because y'all played four
against Lawrence and now he's going to
play something against me which we
discussed at length during the course of
my stay yeah he told me this is
excellent
d5 this was what I was kind of hoping
for because now I think he might as well
know who Lawrence
this is not how chest works certainly
would be much much more fun if Chester G
to work like this I don't think it does
well maybe it does well that's me
regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me and what's worse I will never
hear the end of it my quality of life
has just gone downhill tremendous me
because I'm actually sharing the office
with the guy
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the st. Louis
chess club for the 2018 norm Congress my
name is Ben Simon and as always with the
man with the hat grandmaster josh
Friedel we are in the midst of round
number six which started several hours
ago and is wrapping up rapidly and Josh
where are we right now so far in the
tournament and follow along of course on
us chess champs calm well in the gym
section we have the ones we cover
already addy Patel B mark Parag WA the
pavlova ronzo of his black beat jariabek
karma cool off gray which is black drew
against the leaders tough rule Isola
Kapoor and akshat Ronda beat Dennis
Danish Boros the only game still going
was talked about Brahman as black
against John Bartholomew and it looks
like Tata is gonna catch the ruler and
in fact already has she beats John
Bartholomew as black we see the end of
the game here is this position and it
was quite a game because there were lots
of it played at the end but it looked
like Tata had the upper hand got to this
rook endgame up two pawns and from here
on it was fairly simple conversion but I
can tell you Ben that when you have no
time no conversion is super simple and
after this it looked like things are
over I thought that he might resign here
but he decides the shoulder soldier on
and there's one trick in all of these
positions and she actually fell for it
she played I don't want say fell for it
because it's not the end of the world
she played h2 and the trick of course is
that it looks like it's just over you
can take this pawn and the idea is that
now if rook a to check you have King f3
and you're kind of embarrassed luckily
when you're three pawns to the good it's
not a big deal and after a three it's
pretty much over he tries one last trick
King f3 is a cool move because if you
play a two rook F 2 all of a sudden how
do you win exactly and I've seen this
trick before because I almost had this
in one of my games if King e5 you give a
check go back there's no rook move with
check you take
because and then you can take this pawn
if the King tries to get too close you
start giving checks give checks and this
would be a heartbreaking way to not win
up three pawns however taught them of
course did not fall for this she tried
rook up one check King G to A two and
now there were no more still matrix John
tried but Tata said I insist you take my
rook and finally he gave it up because
obviously this is gonna be with check so
the game was over so nice a few nice
tricks by John at the end you never can
let your guard down but Tata have came
through with the victory so it is her
and stuff rola the two ladies tied for
first place not only the two ladies the
two bottom seats this is unbelievable it
really is and the torn that's not over
yet anything can happen but it shows you
that these ratings do not mean
everything it means that's how
consistent they are that's how they
perform over time but if two Peters
catch fire some other players aren't
playing so well you never know what can
happen
exactly so quite something so that's all
the that's all the games for the GM
norms section hopefully we can get tot
to down here but yeah hopefully hey the
so the first section is all wrapped up
all five games have ended let's take a
look at the standings after six rounds
have been played in their top section so
there they are tata ovens tribulus stop
ruler leading with four points out of
five quite an impressive score in this
field but they're not ahead by much
Pablo Vorontsov Adi Patel just trailing
with three and a half
Parag WA after a couple tough days is
down to three but still not performing
badly
along with hammer Coulomb and John
Bartholomew we see Daniel gonorrhea but
still in last but he did draw the leader
with black and was pressing her so keep
in mind just because the point spread is
pretty big the one and a half was
actually almost beating the four so the
you can't really rule it out by the
pairings in any rate but at the moment
the two bottom seeds are in fact leading
wouldn't it be amazing if they could
hold on and sustain that lead it would
be that would that something I mean I
haven't seen something like that where
the two bottom seeds finish at the top
you see the once in a while but usually
in a round-robin it's kind of rare I
don't think I've seen it just because
you know everyone plays everyone it's
not but this is a compact field the very
top is not that far from the very bottom
so it's believable but it's still pretty
cool what else is going on that we
haven't really taken a look at we're
gonna get tot up in here in just a
moment yeah so the Matenga game I was
mentioning where he was maybe trying to
create a fortress it looks like he
actually really succeeded because not
only we talked about the position where
White had that where White had the f2
pawn well guess what that f2 pawn is
gone remember that G pawn he could have
taken off many times earlier he is
really regretting him and that guy on
the board because now this pawn is very
dangerous obviously this should not this
is not gonna be lost unless he does
something he could play queen h1 check
he could do anything if white wants to
draw but to win this game with this rook
being so solid this pawn being so far
advanced I seriously doubt there are any
winning chances for white at this point
so I really and I saved by met Sango who
remains actually the only and they did
draw in fact they just agreed to a draw
so he remains actually the only
undefeated player in both events thus
far a lot of decisive games and he saved
one he was in big trouble today so I'm
sure he's glad just to skate by with the
drum alrighty well we're gonna take a
break and when we come back we're gonna
have tought to Abraham Ian here she will
be taking a look at her game here on us
chest champs calm for the second day in
a row were always pleased to have her on
the air with us so we'll see you in
about 30 seconds for the conclusion of
today's round and all of the exciting
wrap ups don't go too far
a question on Twitter from dem s I
should not have pronounced that there
was a bit of a champion for those of you
who are new to chess it might look like
ba 3 is an illegal move here because
white masters pawn to square is not one
but it still is something we call hustle
and you can do that but you have to do
it instantly you can't wait for a move
I'd let say 1917 g2 and now try because
[Music]
[Music]
y'all played four against Lawrence and
now he's going to play something against
me which we discussed at length during
the course of my stay
yeah he told me this is that d5 this was
what I was kind of hoping for because
now I think we finally know who Lawrence
this is not how it works
certainly would be much much more fun if
Chester to work like this I don't think
it does well maybe it does well that's
me
regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me and what's worse I will never
hear the end of it my quality of life
has just gone downhill tremendously
because I'm actually sharing the office
with the guy
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to the show
we as you can see Ben Simon has gone
somewhere but luckily he's been replaced
by tata mcgraw Hammond who's now one of
the co-leaders of the event
congratulations on your game
thank you wanna take us through it I'm
not really sure what happen in my game
so if we go back to the opening where he
played a 92 so we didn't if you've seen
this opening before yeah I mean that's
almost every round I'm facing this next
time I'm playing to future opponents do
something else guys come on because I'm
not gonna come on come up with something
new
really so it's all normal stuff so far
rook C 1 D 6 D 5 so this is all fairly
normal 5 so I don't know if I should
play a file or not but I wanted to keep
the option of c6 opening
I doubt my plan hanging I don't think it
can be really too bad cuz 85 and 95 or
where you want your pieces before is
sometimes an option so it doesn't seem
like you have to be in 4 and then that
kind of caught me off chords
yeah 91 93 just to show d3 it looks
weird but the idea is that this night is
actually very nice because it controls
these squares if you want to play f4 it
controls these squares if you want to
play d4 so in general in these positions
this tends to be the nice square for the
night so after 92 yeah because I never
want to take because Cindy's rook is
ready to swing over to King side a5
looks dangerous because take mr. Bates
just coming in so you didn't want to
take because of rook tips so you cover
the square this rook swings over I know
you prefer to play real clips yourself
rather than allow them yeah I mean
there's so many pieces by my king and my
bishop won't be something out of the
game I have no pieces I would agree but
I got a little scared I don't know if
subjectively there's anything but I mean
I don't know these these f5 attacks I
think tend to be usually there's a way
to deal with them especially with as
long as you have ways to open
Center and that's what you chose to do
you played c6 yes I thought I should
play in the center mm-hmm so a 4a I
really hated this move I didn't he
didn't want a lot of B five doesn't
react yes I suppose but this this move
has to be you I think it's the worst
option so takes takes I was surprised to
talk with upon also but I guess sip on
is not ideal yeah yeah honestly I think
f4 was a bit ambitious but okay okay
yeah now politics doesn't make sense
because the pawn structure this is
another moment there wasn't sure if I
should trade nights or play rook e8
because so were you worried about
potential 94 or trying to occupy so sure
if my knight is good enough compared to
his night because my bishop is just
terrible but like that maybe I should
trade and then I'll have if I thought
that soon as I forced him to play b3 I'm
gonna put a queen so on c5 and I can
never lose that position yeah because I
have weaknesses and he doesn't make
sense I thought you might try Bishop c2
d said I never quite time I thought even
here you could maybe try and because I
honestly I'm not afraid of takes cuz I'm
the queen gets the square but but like
if I take takes so here if you try to
play Bishop see if something happens
yes I think yeah he just goes to Ruby
three and then okay so yeah I mean I can
see how there would be problems because
you want to play Queen c7 doesn't want
to be there but it's very concrete yeah
before he's always hanging so he cannot
just do whatever yeah so Queen a kind of
sneaky right trying to come in this way
so you played Bishop a6 but it looks
weird but the idea is just to make sure
this is always hanging rights and if you
provoke b3 you at least never have to
worry about
yeah because here if I play Bishop c8
it's just gonna play it at
rookie maybe rookie three AHA and now I
don't have Bishop discern because rookie
7 and then if I don't do that then he's
gonna play rook every four and he gets
the file and that position is definitely
not gonna be good to me
so you wanted to distract him a little
bit
yeah route p3 I thought was weird like I
really thought he would try b3 rookie 3
and just kind of focus on this file
maybe I thought I just can't lose that
yeah but I don't mean I don't know I I
don't feel like he's actually should be
managed maybe but I don't know I mean
it's it's kind of uh I thought that here
he had to settle down though b3 rookie 3
and kinda keep things together this
looked very strange ah look b3 rook b8 I
mean I thought that this was very risky
rookie 4 and now you play that 5 yeah
now he has to stay somewhere in the
fourth which he played yeah yeah he
doesn't really want to move on the
fourth does he so f5 maybe this move
took him by surprise because honestly
here is yeah but this is why again I
really thought he had to put the pawn on
v3 this looked uh this looks a little
too loose so rook e1 played Queen c5 so
you're happy to trade Queens of course
just so you guys are aware of takes you
I assume B ticks and then takes takes
and the problem is you there's no time
to get this pawn solidly here because it
gets captured this this is also attacked
I guess black and white could try it
brookey 6 but even rook b6 and maybe b3
but yes this rook is not a permanent
guest
okay so Bishop f1 so yeah here I thought
your position was just quite good you
played f/4g for because I thought his
king is a week and I shouldn't trade
Queens anymore uh-huh so you basically
were like you know what I'm gonna I'm
gonna take right now I'm gonna check
meet you yeah but then after next boom I
went to five and I thought okay now my
king is actually really weak actually if
we go back to f4 yo go back one more
move can he take on c5 so it takes I
assume he takes yeah v8
and then I thought his rookie six and
then just like everything's hanging so
and I have Rugby six it just takes on
haha so rookie six with ideas if you
play this move then he takes my which I
also thought maybe it's not stand up the
world but maybe a little bit annoying
know for sure so here I thought I can
actually take on g3 sneaking off so take
on d6 I thought I can take on h2 so you
cannot take MCOs take with a check aha
so King each one you get fate can you
still take this pawn and play here oh
yeah so takes here and I don't know it
still doesn't look completely clear to
me there's rook takes a five takes check
the C pawn hangs I mean so probably
maybe f4 was premature because you can
always take with the D pawn but that
looks very very looks very awkward so
maybe he missed the shot here cuz g4
after this I thought your position had
to be excellent I was surprised you
played Queen c7 I thought you might even
just play g5 to start but yeah Queen d7
but honestly it looks like his king is
just as weak as yours the key is just
gonna be actually I'm not sure my king
is safer than his the way the game
turned out but but you did take on a
four so you couldn't have been too
worried about your game but it's
understandable
so at this point it's kind of like yeah
but you seem to outplay him in the
mutual time scramble I assumed he was
somewhat limited in time or was he did
he got a long time okay so he misses but
you're used to being long time yeah
we're comfortable so here he missed so
take in g5 I almost missed it to rook g7
uh-huh so he forgot that he cannot take
187 in play rooks you wanna
aha so just to show you guys how this
works it looks like you're pinning the
Queen to the king but you can take this
rook check and grab this rook and that's
a few too many pieces again it seems
like a simple tactic but at the same
time when you're low on time you
couldn't miss anything you really can
yeah Bishop g4 word submission page
salmon Oh instead yeah okay Siobhan I
just have fish before and now you cannot
take on g4 because Quincy 400 gauge for
wasn't good enough
oh because the I'm doing a queen yeah
for some reason in my mind this rook
who's not defending alright so here so
here I go before it takes root G 1 and
you have Bishop g4 huh
so now now if rook takes you can take
this rope yeah and take it of takes King
takes well he thought he could do this
and then he said Bishop g4 so you played
rook to you one instead but now you
enter an endgame which should be
comfortably winning so I thought maybe
it rotate six here but I guess I have
check on route g6 so the idea is that
I'll catch through you okay um hey
you're up g3 butter cake sex yeah I
thought you might
you'd have to pitch that guy anyway but
I'm just bringing my king maybe let's
see but I just found my queen saying
don't be careful yeah but I don't know I
mean your King comes up it looks like
yeah but it's definitely a better try
because what happened in the game was
pretty straightforward this rook is just
out of play
no now taking this pawn is always gonna
simply get to a loss King and planning
game so it's never really an option for
whites so yeah and here you seemed once
you activated your rook seems fairly
straightforward yeah and here there was
one last trick but luckily when you're
up three pawns you have some leeway yeah
and there are many ways to win such
positions you can run your King over to
the King over to the Queen side is
fairly simple but you can also do kind
of what you did and yeah here you could
play a three you could even bring your
king over you have plenty of options not
just completely but h2 and this is a
very common trick for those of you at
home so the idea is rook takes and I
think I mentioned this already if rook a
to check King f3 do not take that rook
it will be still me so this is one of
the ways you hold when you're playing
against F and H funds it is that you
oftentimes black tries to ship the King
here so then you check and go behind
just to make sure the King is on and
here I also showed that there's a trick
which is that of a to rook f2 and all of
a sudden yeah it's not a simple the idea
being you give check and go back and if
you approach the pawn you take here and
now check this is not quite Ventura it's
something unnamed as far as I know but
it is a draw cause you always have these
checks and go by but of course you did
not fall for it and now there are tricks
but they're kind of half-hour
Trix yeah I mean here there are no
tricks I mean you can do anything you
want but you decided to do it by force
I thought you'd put rook h1 but you play
and rook up to it but maybe even a
little quicker even a little quicker so
a crazy game again the time pressure
scramble but you got you again found
your way through tied for the lead
what are your feelings going into
tonight's round oh no I guess I'm not
gonna play another Queen's Indian so
that's exciting you might end up in one
anyway
could you play tonight well fine we'll
be sure to find out before the show
wraps up so actually speaking of we're
gonna actually look at the pairings for
the last round so why don't we not the
last round in tonight's round why don't
we take a look for Round seven in the GM
norm section I shot Chandra white
against Bartholomew Daniel Gurevich who
almost got a win but not quite white
against burrows vorontsov white against
so lucky do one of the leaders mark
Parag Oh white against hammer cool off
and are taunted you are playing Adi
Patel as white you get the white pieces
no Queens Indian for you tonight that
must feel good and he did just get a win
though so against paraguas so he's gonna
be feeling pretty confident but again
should be yeah so this is a weird
situation in the tournament because
people can be leading the tournament or
they can be doing well but often times
they're chasing a specific score for you
at 6 for some ruler at 6 but for
everyone else they need 6.5 which is a
lot of points for a GM norm so you can
find yourself in must-win situations
where in a normal tournament you would
not be however a lot of people are still
just trying to play good chess so not so
much let's check out the I am norm
pairings for around 7 yep so much Senko
who barely survived now gets white
against Luis Torres Oh indeed and
actually Luis just lost the tough game
to Joel but now it's so Joba now is
trying to play for first place he gets
white against Stearman and
the other pairings also we have tensile
target trying to bounce back against GU
Josh colas trying to keep his run going
against grab in ski who barely was not
able to beat my Cinco and then Brandon
Jacobson still kind of on the bad luck
train gets white against Justin Wang who
is trying to also make the most of his
tournament so plenty of great games
tonight we will not be there to watch
them with you but be sure to tune in on
us chest champs comm any last thoughts
that's it that's it we're done thinking
for today so I hope you guys enjoyed
this up the show tune in tomorrow at 2
p.m. on us chest champs we will be back
to catch round 8 action life and don't
miss it so hope you guys enjoyed the
show we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
you
[Music]